you know it's always good to have
positive role models in life but in a
country where those are often hard to
come by it seems like sometimes you have
to settle for negative role models and
the useful thing about a negative role
model is that he can show you exactly
how
not to respond in a given situation
which will also tell you exactly how you
should respond you know he's providing a
road map in his own way and that's the
great service that cowards provide for
all of us and that's why we should be
grateful in some ways to leftist
comedian patton oswalt today who over
the course of the past two days has
unwittingly offered himself as a prime
example of everything you shouldn't be
and shouldn't do as a man or simply as a
as a human being so it all began um well
really it began it began shortly after
oswalt was born i guess it takes a
lifetime to make cowards of this quality
but we don't have time to go back that
far so we'll start this week
just a few days ago when oswalt was
performing at a comedy club apparently
in seattle and his uh his as he says
dear friend of 34 years dave chappelle
texted him and invited him to come next
door to the arena where chappelle was
performing um
doing his own performance and he said
that that oswald could do a guest set
there at his performance so chappelle
was at an arena because he was a big
popular comedian and pat and oswalt was
at a small club because nobody cares
about him but chappelle said why don't
you come over and you can perform in
front of my bigger audience you know
it's a nice thing to offer
um i now why did chappelle offer that i
guess chappelle was angry with his
audience that night and wanted to punish
them by subjecting them to patent oswald
i don't know we can't be sure exactly
but oswalt took him up on on the
invitation
and later that night he took a picture
with dave chappelle and posted it to his
instagram
but the rage mob didn't like that
the trans bullies and their lackeys
decided that patton oswalt shouldn't be
friends with dave chappelle
why well of course because dave
chappelle has opinions about gender that
are pretty
well really pretty liberal actually all
things considered but still slightly out
of lockstep with the orthodoxy of the
day
so he's a heretic he's he's now we
should remember he's he's just barely a
heretic
his opinions about gender are still by
the standards of
uh like 10 years ago
are pretty radical far left but by the
standards of today they're you know
maybe moderate at best
and that means that nobody can associate
with them the rage mob the trans mob the
raging trans mop yelled at patton oswald
for daring to continue a friendship with
a man that he's known for three decades
i mean and how dare he really oswalt
didn't even ask the strangers on the
internet for permission
before choosing to continue his
association with this person
and they were stunned by the insult and
they let him know it
and so of course what does pat oswalt do
well he apologizes profusely and at
length
complete with a photo of him sitting
ruffly at his desk like a child in time
out hoping that daddy isn't mad at him
anymore here was his follow-up post on
monday after desperately explaining
how he ended up in the proximity of dave
chappelle and trying to justify his
decision to be photographed in the
heretics company
um rather than simply stoning him to
death on the spot and setting his corpse
on fire as a true ally would have done
oswalt says this
we oswald and chappelle
100 disagree about transgender rights
and representation
i support trans people's rights anyone's
rights to live safely in the world as
their fullest selves
for all the things he's helped me evolve
on i'll always disagree with where he
stands now on transgender issues but i
also don't believe a seeker like him is
done evolving learning
you know someone that long see the
struggles and changes it's impossible to
cut them off impossible not to be
hopeful and open and cheer them on
also i've been carrying a lot of guilt
about friends i've cut off who had views
with which i couldn't agree or changed
in ways i couldn't live with sometimes i
wonder
did i and others cutting them off make
them dig their heels in deeper
fuel their ignorance with a nitro boost
of resentment in spite
i'm an lgbtq ally i'm a loyal friend
there's friction in those traits that i
need to reconcile myself and not let not
let cause feelings of betrayal in anyone
else and i'm sorry truly sorry that i
didn't consider the hurt this would
cause or the depth of that hurt
i've been messaging a lot on ig today
and the back and forth has really helped
guide me in the writing of this
i deleted a lot a lot of posts in the
comment thread critical ones from lgbtq
writers and posts by turf
anti-trans orcs looking for clicks and
giggles
i wanted a nice comment thread about the
pick with my friend ugg
so easy to think someone else needs
growth and miss the need in yourself
but i'm gonna keep trying
so there you go he's sorry truly sorry
but he wants you to know that he's only
remaining friends with the guy that he's
known for almost four decades in an
effort to cure him of his ignorance and
help him evolve
so this is like this is an evangelical
mission you see
he's hoping to convert chappelle to to
induct him into the gender ideology cult
and that's the only reason you're
staying friends with him
now naturally he never explains
what chappelle is wrong about when it
comes to gender
he also never explains how exactly
anyone could be hurt much less hurt with
such great
depth
just because a comedian they like is
friends with a comedian they don't like
but those questions are irrelevant
he is just a mouse much like the one he
voices in the one single pixar movie
that my kids refuse to watch because
they say it's boring scurrying about
fearful and and confused
i just hope that in all his scurrying he
doesn't accidentally bump into this
other comedian who has said way more
problematic things about trans people so
patton oswalt uh watch out for this guy
his name is also patton oswalt watch you
said this is for like families and kids
because this sounds really grim and
creepy well you didn't let me finish
because we're also going to have men in
bright clothing and makeup up time out
do you mean like
like transvestites right
well technically yes but they're going
to keep going so that they're clowns
you realize a clown is just a
transvestite that doesn't stop
like if you like if you
if you saw a guy in lipstick and i
should be like timmy leave him alone
that's his own thing the guy's like oh
no hang on
like oh timmy he's a wonderful clown get
over there
i didn't know you'd use a whole tube of
lipstick on one cheek please
entertain my child
run at him out of the darkness he'll
love it
well i don't know how long ago that was
but it didn't look like it was all that
long ago
and there is of course a direct link
here
out of all the adults
bowing to cancel culture now and
especially to trans cancel culture to
lgbt cancer culture
precisely none of them
have obeyed these rules their whole
lives
because these rules as they stand right
now didn't exist their whole lives
most of them being empty gutless cowards
have lived their whole lives
trying to avoid the see the sin of of
wrong think
so they've been trying to engage in
group think and avoid wrong think their
whole lives but the problem is that the
thoughts which qualify as wrong and
right
tend to change
and what this means is that by obeying
the thought police of today
you will inevitably end up disobeying
the thought police of tomorrow
because the rules are arbitrary and they
change and it's designed that way
and because we live in in eternal now
where nothing is ever allowed to simply
stay in the past
and we're all called potentially to
answer for everything we've ever said or
done no matter when we said or did it
the people have been trying to stay up
on the rules will always be in violation
of them
it's a losing game
but it's the only one they know how to
play
it it's too late now for a guy like
oswald to suddenly grow a spine a mind
of his own an intellectual identity of
his own
he's doomed to finish his life as he's
lived until now lying prostrate before
the mob
begging to be loved and accepted or at
least pitied if he can't have love and
acceptance
you know a few years ago when oswalt was
jumping on the dog dog pile to slander
the covington catholic kids as racists
he tweeted this about them
he said that they are quote bland
frightened forgettable kids who will
grow up grow up to be bland frightened
forgotten adult wastes
that was a grown man talking about 15
year old kids at the time by the way
but he should have been talking to a
mirror because he described himself and
his ilk perfectly
bland frightened forgettable
couldn't have said it better myself
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated